hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast novel precision medicine that
exploit approximately by dr. James
prudence I'm Christina jewel elaborate
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational seminar is presented
by labyrinth the leading scientific
social networking website and provider
of virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
this webcast is designed to be
interactive so we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to get to as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the side window by
clicking the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window
now if you have any technical problems
viewing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or submit your problem to the
green Q&A button on the lower left I
would now like to introduce today's
speaker dr. James prudence currently dr.
James prudence thurs a new chief
executive officer and chairman of the
board at centrum a biotechnology company
focused on developing precision
therapies for diseases with high unmet
need while exploring interesting natural
products dr. pruden and his colleagues
discovered that the all-powerful sodium
potassium ATP ace was interacting with
multiple proteins that's a self-service
the biology of the various interacting
proteins indicated an evolutionary
pattern of energy regulation coupled to
growth motility and survival this
discovery led to the invention of ec
technology which allows for the
unprecedented precise delivery of drugs
currently the company has discovered
multiple EDC for cancer and autoimmune
disease prior to centos dr. fernette
serves as chief science officer and
board member at Aragon Biosciences now
luminex where the invented gene code and
multi coated technologies that
incorporate an expanded genetic code
incom real time and multiplex diagnostic
assays before arrogant doctor prudence
invented in the vader technology while
at third ways now robotic invaders
complementary to pcr so does not amplify
DNA making invader more accurate and
easier to use today invader is being
used by whole logic and exact Sciences
in their diagnostic products quieter
third wave dr. prudent receive a PhD in
chemistry at the UC Berkeley under the
direction of Professor Peter detials and
his BS in bacteriology in medical
microbiology at the University of
wisconsin-madison he has over a hundred
publication patents and patent
application she is a recipient of the
frost & sullivan products of the Year
award and biotechnology industry
organization innovation award and will
now turn it over to dr. James credit for
his presentation dr. Gordon thank you
Christina for that great introduction
I'll just step right in and get started
here I'm a CEO of Centro so I'm going to
give you a little bit of background on
exactly what we do here and what we
found we go to the second slide here we
kind of think about delivering drugs up
similarly to how a postman actually
brings his drugs or excuse me his
packages his envelopes is unisex man
brings the packages right to a zip code
in a particular city or town this is
actually pretty precise you to think
about it the world is a pretty large
place but a few numbers can bring that
particular package right to where you
want it I was just showing 22 maybe not
so precise nail mijnheer but you can get
the point antibodies are basically the
same type of delivery system when we
talk about antibody drug conjugates so
look at this slide we see that the
mailman is the actual antibody and the
package is the small molecule drug which
is attached to it we go to the next
slide the first step in a DC's activity
is really to have that that antibody or
mailman actually bring the package to
the house or the cell and that cell
could be most any type of disease cell
that the antibody can recognize if we
didn't look at the next step of an ADC
is actually the internalization which is
basically bringing the mailman into the
house along with the package and then
the next step is actually dropping the
package ah and in this case the package
really isn't all that precise because
you know could be going to a number of
people that live within the house or the
business so there's a name on it
typically in a package but not so much
in an ATC the next step is to set that
package to to actually do its job so
whatever it is it has to act in an ATC
case it's a drug acting on either
tubulin or DNA so these four steps are
quite complicated and they have some
some some deficiencies for example the
antibody can only recognize a single
protein then that protein may actually
be on the surface of normal cells or
cells that you don't want to destroy the
second step of internalization is
actually a very slow and cumbersome
problem you you can imagine if the
mailman had to get a signature or
actually enter the house of large
package is not as easy as dropping it
into a mailbox if you look at three the
next step is the actual releasing of the
package and in in an in ec case that
means is the linker or the connection of
the drug to the antibody actually you've
gotta gotta break down or if you
modified so that that drug can actually
get off of the antibody and so you can
imagine that then all of a sudden that
drug can be floating around and actually
get out of the cell or
target other other particular molecules
in the cell that may be toxic and then
the fourth is that really the drug
binding which so the concentration has
to be high and it's that job does get
out of the cells which are our pumps
thats actually take it out you can build
up resistance so we ask the question if
we can build a next generation of
molecules where there's only one step
I'm the left you see that this would
maybe be no internalization they'll
break down which would lead to novel
mechanisms that you have to find and
actually you could actually go after new
targets otherwise you could think about
antibodies that are targeting proteins
that don't get into the cell you can
actually have antibodies that don't need
to get in yourself so this would be a
factor acting more stable very specific
type of system if those two targets the
drug target aiming the body target were
actually in close proximity so I'm going
to introduce what we do here is called
extracellular drug conjugates and really
what these do is we exploit the idea
that there are multiple proteins that
actually form complexes on the cell
surface and if one of them can be a
druggable target then the antibody can
actually be very focused on bringing it
to the cell but only when those two
proteins are in close proximity they
enhance maybe a disease state you'd
actually get activity and so it brings
an extra level of specificity to the
system so if we look at what it has to
be to actually drive this type of
activity you're actually are thinking
about proximity effect effect and the
idea of proximity is really really
fundamental in the areas of science but
I just want to first just talk about
looking at this on a real molecular
level so on the bottom left we show that
there's a target cell and in this case
we fluorescently labeled two proteins
that inner
in blue you can actually see the nucleus
of the cell and then I'm a surface the
ring around that nucleus is either a
green dye or a red dye and then when
they come in close contact they actually
form a yellow color this is called
spreading but it actually represents in
this case two proteins that do come in
close proximity to one another so if we
go to the top left we see the two
complex proteins in this little bitty
area that I have marked and then if we
get an even closer we can start actually
looking at the idea of a package now in
the mailbox not so much having to get
into the house just putting it into the
mailbox and now that that package is in
the mailbox the actual drug is actually
meaning it's in the pocket and it can
actually inhibit or act on whatever
targets you're interested in so this is
the idea of the exercise drug conjugate
and I'm going to go into some detail
explaining what we've actually
determined is very useful for and what
targets we've gone after so if we look
at the similarity first between the ADC
and the EDC these are all things that a
company needs to think about those the
antibody are the exercise drug
conjugates allow you to make it package
it administer it and have all of the FDA
requirements that an ADC does and in
these cases yes it does now the
differences are are what I kind of
talked about before the drug location is
different the EDC is outside and sell
the linker requirements are different we
never want the drug to leave the
antibody but there's got to be a
distance that you have to span between
those two proteins that are in close
proximity and then obviously they have
to be in close proximity to activate the
internalization is not required it
doesn't require a breakdown
and in our case the EDC's killed by a
different process than a pop ptosis we
found that they killed by a system
called pyroptosis which is basically
blowing up of the cell and not releasing
a lot of their contents that can lead to
some sort of immune activation which in
some cases may be good but too much can
be bad now the great that being antibody
examples are interests intercepting and
rituximab two huge blockbuster drugs
ABC's cannot use for Tulsa mAb and edc's
have been found not to be very useful
with perceptive so you open up an area
of a new set of protein targets and
antibodies now how do the edc's that we
use work today well basically we're
targeting a protein that we call the
all-powerful sodium APPA and the reason
why we call it the all-powerful because
if you build up too much sodium in the
cell the cell will die and so what we've
done is we've targeted with a natural
product a actual molecule if that's made
by mammals as well as plants called
cardiac glycoside or steroidal glycoside
but basically a steroid ring that has an
additional ena line attached and they
become extremely powerful inhibitors of
this sodium potassium a TPA which uses
more ATP than any other protein in your
body so it seems to be a quite of
important protein just to that fact
alone time you see the antibody on the
top and then the linker you could see a
little better in the blow upwards that
light blue that connects the antibody to
the drug it has to be a certain distance
so we can span the distance between
where the antibodies has the bound
linker all the way down to where the
site of the drug is the grid of the next
aisle this is giving back to what I said
about the actual EDC blowing up itself
on the top is really a fluorescently
labeled EDC bound to the cell and you
can see it's not internalizing but at
the bottom right you can see after
addition of the EDC the cells start to
balloon up and the simple fact of the
matter is that sodium builds up inside
the cell and things go haywire and so
the cells become very very ill dice can
now get in so that's where the green guy
is and the cells die this is all
publishing in our paper in Nature
molecular therapy if you'd like to go to
it and read in more detail now do 80
feet kill cancer is really the question
and this I think is at least in in the
mouse model we're seeing a very nice
correlative agreement with that we load
in more and more of the EDC we see more
and more reduction of tumor growth over
time and then are they safe and I'm
going to show you a little more about
this in the monkey studies but in
general what we're trying to do like
with every ADC is to take a drug make it
more toxic because you're going to load
more into the target cell of interest
through that delivering it with the
mailman or the antibody and there's the
same time we're keeping it away from
self you don't want to kill because they
don't form the complexes in our case on
the cell surface and so you see that
that yellow line is opening up that
therapeutic index by about a thousand
fold just by putting the antibiotic now
there are three portions to an EDC the
drug the linker and the antibody see
then I'm going to go through each one of
these and how they're different or the
same as with an ADC so first the drug so
I'm on this slide slide 20 you can see
that we've actually done a lot of work
on the SAR of this molecule really
looking at all the little functions of
what these particular model these
particular drugs do
and we modify one so that it not only
can be attached to the antibody but also
it's extremely active and not a
substrate for a number of different
enzymes that could break it down in the
body so we look at drug mechanism men as
i mentioned we're blocking the sodium
APPA sodium removal is required for all
cell growth interestingly is that is
that sodium comes in in a number of
different ways and that's why it builds
up so quickly for example waste products
that have to come out of the cell
actually bring in sodium as a code
transporter so does glucose but it comes
into the cell and brings in a sodium
litter I put a couple other small
molecules that actually use sodium to
transport without energy so as the Sunni
build up your body ends up using a lot
of sodium system pump that extra sodium
out and so ATP gets gets used up quite
quickly and so there needs to be more
and more nutrients especially in
diseases like cancer or even autoimmune
disease where your immune system becomes
activated to your own self so the drug
binding that if we look into close-up
molecular structure of it you can see in
the top left is our molecule which has
the six-membered ring pointing right to
the purple circle which is a potassium
and locks it in place that doesn't allow
now sodium to get out or potassium to
get in this was all done work done by
Paul Neeson our advisor here at Central
now the linker so I'm 24 you'll see that
this data is quite intriguing because on
the top we're changing the length of the
linker while it's attached to the drug
and the antibody and as we make that
link there longer and longer we've seen
more and more activity in fact when the
leaker is very small we see very little
tivity now on the bottom we said well
what if the antibody got degraded and
the drug got released we actually know
now that I'm on the bottom we're in the
first case where we don't have a linker
at all the drugs quite active but as
legal a blinker and then increase its
length it becomes less and less active
so this sort of this is the key
ingredient to this concept where some
people would worry about the drug on an
antibody floating around with a target
outside of the cell that these would be
rather toxic but the fact that you have
that long linker and the proximity that
the antibody places it makes that drug
linker conjugates very very active once
it binds to the protein complex on the
cell surface now the antibody the first
antibody we looked at was a was a
protein called disappearance it turns
out to be a known protein that interacts
with the sodium a cpa and it's also a
target that is considered a metastatic
target prognosticator for metastatic
cancers there's a load of other data on
this and I suggest that if you're
interested to go look at this cancer
letters paper that was published in 2007
but in general this is a very very nice
marker for a number of proteins
important than cancer it seems to be
upregulated quite significantly in
metastatic types of campus now the next
target is EDC is our EDC 8 which targets
CD 30 years and many of you may know
that are that are scientist of the
oncology filled with c-38 is the target
for dare to the madness and showing some
very nice activity in in the actual
clinical trials as well as now it's
prescribed for people
with multiple myeloma I'm cd38 is a is a
libelous hydroxylase but it also has
some very interesting connections to
cancer that I had mentioned at the
bottom you two seem to be quite closely
associated at least complex on the cell
surface to sodium to fascinate to PA
especially when these cells are are
especially when when when the cells are
a cancer is stage and then I'm going to
talk a little about cd20 which is the
target for a touch to mAb and of course
we all know that there's Deborah
touching that is an excellent drill but
it also has some fallbacks where the
fact that it works through a cdc and a
TCC activity makes it a problem with
certain patients where they become
resistant to it and then of course we
have the double hit lymphoma targets
which is the most aggressive form of
non-hodgkin's lymphoma and I talked a
little about the bottom of why cardiac
glycosides and inhibiting the sodium h
cph have been shown to be very good
drugs for these three targets see Mick
mcl-1 as well as bcl-2 and so I put down
some papers that you can go and look at
at a later time now if we look at the
precision on this slide I'm showing EDC
one but the basically is the chart at
the bottom shows the ec50 values higher
bar means that these are more active
drugs they have a lower you see 50 value
and then on the right you see drugs that
you see this Korea clob EDC that has
very little activity these are all based
on different cell types that express
disappearance or on the left you see
disappear an expression is high you see
activity high on the right where
disappeared is low or it's over in a
normal state you see that the EDC
activity is low in no cases have we ever
seen good activity for EDC one if the
cells are not expressing disappear
now the question then is is do we really
know what the targets are and so what we
did is some knockdown experiment you can
see on the top right in the purple is
that if we not down the alpha-1 subunit
of the sodium a TPA which is really the
key target in cancer cells we see that
the activity of our ADC actually goes up
now we can knock down all the ATP a so
we only knock down about ninety to
ninety-five percent so the self still
grow and you can actually see you need
left EDC to kill those cells but the
CDC's become really potent when you do
and that's because you have to have a
certain number of atb aces to survive
and the less you have in the south the
left CDC's of me now if you knock out
this is here and you can see on the
bottom right that that line is flatlined
meaning no cells are dying because
disappearin is not is not i'm a self
surface any longer so then if we go to
the ebc eight case which targets cd38
many of you may know that cd38 can be
induced to be expressing itself surface
by low levels of atra an answer is a is
a is a used compound for certain types
of diseases and it seems to be quite
safe and human but what's interesting
you can see from the charts on the
bottom is that if we take a cell line
that doesn't express cd38 without adding
natura you see basically no activity and
then all of a sudden on the right we
made a number of different antibodies
that bound to different areas or
epitopes on the cd38 and in this case
all of those are now active when they
are made into an EDC or in this case CDC
at EDC eight and they become extremely
active now that after it's been added in
cd38 is them express
so then the question is what's the
toxicity of the parts in this case we
use our EDC 9 which is the rituximab
antibody and this chair basically shows
that the EDC in red in the in the middle
church is the most active followed by
the drug itself and then you see way off
on to the right you see the drug linker
and then the drug linker with rituximab
or rituximab along at the bottom you
could see actual graph of the different
molecules that are presented in the
middle of ec50 curve data so in general
ed c9 is quite active a controlled
conjugate or control EDC which doesn't
target in fact in this case of target
cd47 which doesn't interact on the cell
surface but is expressed is very
inactive even when you add it in
combination with a custom and so then
what is the efficacy of these of these
EDC so first I want to show EDC one this
again targets disappearance and you can
see in the non Hodgkin's and former
model you get very nice activity in
complete regression on some cases you
could cure in the middle you see it
swords in the middle mm of light you see
two drug-resistant strains one is a spc
one cell line and the other is a is a p
dec model or patients arrive pancreatic
cancer model where the tumors were taken
were resected direct become a patient
and then placed into amino incompetent
mice in this case we combine it with
gems are and you can see that not only
did we get regression but we also got
some cures of these animals where the
two alone were not very active so it's
showing this affinity between gems are
as well as EDC one is quite significant
in both cases in this case we're looking
at EDC eight now targeting cd38 and one
of the
in this case this is a rainbow cell line
one of the strong drug that's used in
the clinic today is called chop and we
see that over the this particular span
of time we're seeing that very large
tumors in the mice that were dose of the
18 it's a very aggressive tumor we
actually see most of the mice dying
before you see any of the tumors
starting to grow out in the edca case so
this again is showing that this
particular conjugate is quite active in
immuno incompetent might even better
than then chop a pretty aggressive toxic
treat so then what do we what do we see
for EDC 9 and in this case we're
comparing rituximab directly and you'll
see that it was a single dose of either
your Testament War II dc-9 we're seeing
very good tumor regression in the EDC
nine case in fact many of these animals
survived and of course there's always
the case where some don't so we're
looking at some averages and we're
seeing that the PDC nine is is out
competing over touch and abalone so now
are these drugs safe and the answer to
that is it seems to be at least in
monkeys at this time so the specificity
of this data is showing when this is Ed
c9 of course it's going up to cd20 this
particular drug targets cd20 expressing
b-cells so we're looking at cd19 cd20
positive or feeding Tony positive on the
bottom left to graph and you can see
that immediately these B cells get
depleted and then after about 20 to 30
days we see that the B cells start to
come back normally now you look at T
cells natural killer cells helper
t-cells you don't see this kind of a
drop in fact most of the cases you don't
see really any change
the fact that these are percentages of
detail levels are going down so you do
see a little increase but that's based
on the percentage of cells in the blood
what's interesting is on this side slide
40 you actually see that we can we can
multi dose up these monkeys and actually
see the same effect over and over and
over again in the first dose we see what
you saw before we let the b-cells go to
back to normal then we hit him again we
see and drastically get depleted and
then the third dose was a smaller dose
but it was right after the cells the be
so started to come back up and you can
see this they go back down again now we
learned what that cytokine response
because clearly you don't want some sort
of cytokine storm in this case and so we
compared it to regionalize 1979 which is
there by specific and this is a CD 20 23
by specific antibody and they do see
I'll to interfere on a tee and up levels
going up we did not see those we
actually tested il-6 as well and we
didn't see il-6 levels up going up
appreciably so this is very interesting
and very important as far as we didn't
see those kind of cytokine responses
that could be worrisome in the clinic
now can you produce these the answer is
yes on this slide we're showing multiple
lots being made and then what we use is
a is a quick hick analysis showing that
each one of those EDC conjugates that we
make are very similar and at the bottom
right you can see that we're looking at
aggregation in fact we actually believe
in a lot of cases that because of the
long linker we use we see left
aggregation so the antibody conjugates
behave quite well and are extremely
stable not only on the shelf but they
also seem very stable in serum and then
you could see the invivo stability is
about on par with most
abc's getting cleared on a half-life of
up three days so i just want to recap
what I went over is when we have a new
generation of antibody drug conjugates
that's making their way to clinic this
looked at protein protein complexes and
uses proxima effect for activity the
precision is basically can be measured
by the length of the linker which is
typically around 100 to 200 angstroms in
length these are effective we're seeing
cheers and then you know cop incompetent
mice and we're seeing drastic changes in
V cell levels and amino competent
monkeys we also believe that they're
safe they're clearly safe in rodents but
they're also safe in in primates um
sinal monkeys as well as we don't see
the cytokine increase or storm that
sometimes antibodies or antibody
conjugates can bring now we also show
the robust reproducible long-term
stability of these VDC so we think we
have a nice system in and and I think
it's going to be interesting to see
others other types of EDC's coming down
the pipeline in the future so I want to
thank you and Christi I'll give it back
to you taking off your credit for that
informative presentation now before we
do get started on the Q&A session I
would like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window I will try to
answer as many questions as we can and
if we do run out of time dr. person will
answer questions via email after the
presentation okay got recruited our
first question is so let's put this on
how do you think they will perform in
human
now the question right that's the
million-dollar question and of course we
don't know at this point but that's why
we have done so much background work we
hope and we believe that they will be
safe which is our number one concern
with any type of of cytotoxin that you
attach to an antibody but in general if
we look at the data where we're getting
now we think they're going to be quite
safe the real question I think is what
is going to be the dosing regimen what
disease where we go after with this
initially we're looking at the hardest
to treat diseases but clearly diseases
that don't involve high doses and where
you just want to remove a certain
population of cells I think it's going
to work out pretty well how many
antibody are typically needed typically
we only need and we've done this a
number of times we only need one maybe
two drugs / f a b and what that means if
we use just the fa b portion of the
antibody just the binding portion we we
actually see that we actually see that
we only need one drug so it really but I
think it's really going to depend on the
protein complex some cases we could
probably imagine that there will be
multiple ATP aces close to a single
antibiotic target in that case you
probably would want a few more drugs
typically we use about four drugs for
antibody and that's really manufacturing
issues much more than in a scientific
chemistry issue one last question oh
[Music]
goodness that the drug target is outside
of the cell why do you think they these
are so less active on cells that do not
have the antibody target yeah great
question um well you can see from the
data I showed on one of the slides about
linkers and this is discussed a little
bit tonight in the manuscript that we
published this year but in general when
we start to add what I call spinach or
larger parts of the molecule like the
antibody or the linker to the small
molecule drugs we see less and less
activity and so the question is is why
do they work anyway and the thought is
is that the antibody actually increases
the local concentration of the drug to
the point where it is always going to be
bound to be a CPA's during the process
by which the antibody binds to its
target so the antibody found the local
concentration of that drug becomes
extremely high in the molar ratio so we
believe that it is for the majority of
time is found in the pocket and
inhibiting the ACPs where if it wasn't
attached to the antibody they would be
circulating in the entire body and that
would be much less active
I would like to once again thanks dr.
James prudent for his presentation today
dr. pertain to any final comments for
our audience well I just want to thank
all of you for joining on listening in
and if you have any questions please
feel free to contact here up here at
centro that info at spencers pharma com
we hope that these were sunday be a big
plus for the set of tools we have to
treat diseases especially for people
that are very sick and ill and have
devastating disease of cancer thank you
again and thank you again doctor today I
would also like to thank labyrinth so
making today's education webcam possible
now today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through May
twenty-third 2017 you will receive an
email from laggards alerting you when
this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues so a
main have missed today's live event
thanks for joining us can we hope to see
you next time goodbye